hola este es el vídeo de química
esencial número 9 y hablaremos de la
espectrometría de masas que es una
técnica con la que podemos separar
átomos isótopos e incluso fragmentos de
moléculas basándonos en su masa así que
es una técnica muy efectiva pero antes
de entrar en los detalles me gustaría
hablar un poco sobre john dalton john
dalton fue uno de los pioneros de la
química moderna en una conferencia de
1803 presentó la teoría atómica de
dalton veamos que ha cambiado en los
últimos 200 años él creía número uno que
los elementos están hechos de partículas
extremadamente pequeñas llamadas átomos
también creía que los átomos de un
determinado elemento son del mismo
tamaño masa y otras propiedades y que
los átomos de diferentes elementos
difieren en tamaño masa y otras
propiedades él creía que los átomos no
se pueden subdividir
o destruir que los átomos de diferentes
elementos se combinan en una relación
simple de números enteros para formar
compuestos químicos y número 5 en las
reacciones químicas los átomos son
combinados separados o re arreglados
entonces analizando estos cinco puntos
yo solo encuentro dos cambios en el
primero todos los átomos del mismo
elemento tendrán exactamente la misma
masa no recuerden que existen los
isótopos que son un mismo elemento pero
con diferente número de neutrones y el
otro punto es que si podemos subdividir
a los átomos porque podemos estudiar la
fusión y la ficción que son un poco
diferentes a la química que normalmente
conocemos pero fuera de eso tal tony
hizo un gran trabajo y en este vídeo
vamos a enfocarnos en el punto número 2
la identificación de isótopos entonces
la espectrometría de masas es una forma
en la que podemos modificar la teoría
atómica de dalton mediante la
identificación de
isótopos y recuerden los isótopos son
aquellos átomos del mismo elemento pero
que tienen una masa diferente debido al
número de neutrones que contiene pero lo
que se hace es calcular un promedio de
la masa atómica o también conocida como
peso atómico y eso es lo que vemos en la
tabla periódica ahora la espectrometría
de masas también nos puede servir para
analizar átomos individuales identificar
cuáles son los átomos presentes en una
muestra o incluso podemos romper grandes
macromoléculas y analizar sus fragmentos
ahora un espectrómetro de masas consiste
en tres partes tenemos unión y zador un
analizador de masas y un detector
primero veamos que hay en el guionista
d'or bueno el guión y zador tiene que
estar completamente vacío tenemos que
quitar todas las partículas de gas que
haya adentro del espectrómetro porque de
lo contrario no va a funcionar después
lo que hacemos es colocar la muestra que
puede ser un sólido
con gas vamos a inyectar lo en este tubo
ionizador y luego vamos a golpear la
muestra con electrones es decir que los
electrones se van a mover a través de la
muestra tenemos un pequeño tubo de rayos
catódicos que produce todos esos
electrones y así es como podemos
arrancar los electrones de la muestra al
mismo tiempo que se crea un cierto
número de iones positivos entonces aquí
vamos a ironizar la muestra seguir
haciendo la muestra pero estará ionizado
y sin electrones ok ahora vamos con el
analizador de masas aquí sólo tenemos
dos partes un campo eléctrico que
observen que es negativo porque queremos
mover los iones al analizador de masas y
después tenemos un imán que direcciona
circularmente el desplazamiento de los
iones darle dirección a los iones es
como dar la vuelta en una esquina y por
ejemplo si estamos muy pesados es más
difícil dar la vuelta entonces aquí es
en donde sabremos cuál es la diferencia
entre las
de esos iones y finalmente vamos con el
detector el detector consiste en dos
cosas un multiplicador de electrones que
esencialmente es una placa en la que
cuando choca un electrón se desprenden
otros electrones que a su vez chocan con
la siguiente placa hasta que obtenemos
una señal y esa señal tiene que ser
amplificada pero también podemos
enviarla a una computadora y así
podremos obtener el espectro que generan
las diferentes masas ahora lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es calibrar el
dispositivo y eso cómo se hace bueno
empezamos enviando a algunos iones y
miren aquí este ión no golpeó el
detector porque bueno eso es porque la
fuerza del imán está muy alta y al
disminuir la fuerza del electroimán si
lanzamos otro ion podemos ver que ahora
el imán no es lo suficientemente fuerte
pero bueno simplemente lo ajustamos y
ahora a lanzar más iones podemos ver que
ya calibramos el espectrómetro
cuál de estos iones será más pesado
bueno los iones más pesados son los que
no pueden dar la vuelta muy bien así que
terminan por aquí mientras que los iones
más ligeros terminan por acá ok ahora
analicemos la muestra así es como se ven
los resultados al crear un espectro aquí
tendremos las diferentes masas y aquí la
intensidad si la intensidad es alta
podremos ver picos y eso significa que
tenemos muchos iones con ese peso
atómico específicamente entonces hagamos
una prueba con el cloro el cloro
solamente tiene dos isótopos estables
cloro 35 y cloro 37 veamos qué pasa
cuando analizamos el cloro con el
espectrómetro de masas
ok lo que encontramos es que
efectivamente hay dos tipos de iones
porque tenemos dos picos y miren uno
corresponde al cloro 37 que tiene los
iones más pesados estos que tenemos aquí
y que nos dieron la vuelta tan
fácilmente
a ver veamos nuevamente cómo se movieron
los iones aquí podemos ver que los iones
de cloro 37 no dan muy bien la curva y
también podemos ver que tenemos más
iones que corresponden a una masa
atómica de 35 ok y una vez que tenemos
esto podemos calcular la masa atómica
promedio y como la calculamos bueno aquí
tengo unos valores que tomé de wikipedia
para los dos isótopos estables que
existen en el cloro y estas son las
masas actuales basadas en el número de
protones neutrones y electrones que
tienen y aquí tenemos la abundancia
aproximadamente el 75 por ciento de
átomos de cloro corresponden al cloro 35
y el 24 por ciento
floro 37 por eso este pico es tres veces
más intenso que éste y como calculamos
la masa atómica promedio o también
conocida como peso atómico bueno
simplemente calculamos la masa por la
abundancia de uno de los isótopos más la
masa por la abundancia del otro entonces
en este caso como sólo tenemos dos
isótopos sólo tenemos que hacer este
cálculo pero si tuviéramos muchos
isótopos simplemente vamos sumando y
multiplicando la masa por la abundancia
de cada una entonces vamos a sustituir
los valores la masa del isótopo amd es
aproximadamente igual a 34.97 y la vamos
a multiplicar por la abundancia que es
de aproximadamente 75 por ciento y luego
sumamos la masa del otro isótopo que es
el cloro 37 por su abundancia y
finalmente obtenemos 35.45 eso es lo que
encontramos en la tabla
entonces cuando vemos estos valores en
la tabla periódica en realidad estamos
viendo la masa atómica promedio ahora es
muy importante que sepan que un
espectrómetro de masas se puede usar
para muchas otras cosas no solamente
para átomos e isótopos de un solo
elemento también podemos analizar los
átomos que hay en una molécula o incluso
podemos analizar fragmentos en
macromoléculas como por ejemplo aquí
tenemos mioglobina que es una proteína
muy grande y lo que podemos hacer es
analizarla con un espectrómetro de masas
para saber qué aminoácidos contiene
entonces recuerden que si los picos son
altos eso significa que tenemos más de
este aminoácido y generalmente lo que se
mide está en mz por la relación de masa
y carga lo aprendieron aprendieron cómo
usar los datos de la espectrometría de
masas para identificar elementos y la
masa de los átomos individuales de un
elemento recuerden todo se resume
curva si los iones pueden dar la curva o
no dependerá de su masa y podemos
analizar el espectro para conocer su
abundancia